I think I was moving something.
I think it accidentally hit the button that goes to... that goes to my gaming setup.
And I didn't notice.
I really only agreed to this stream because I was like, oh yeah, you know, every single day this week, I've woken up before or around 7 a.m.
my time.
So I was like, oh, I'll totally be fine.
The alarm went off.
I was like, oh, it's time.
There's also a leaf blower going around these parts.
He might be gone, actually.
Don't yon again, I'm gonna yon.
I can't help it.
But hopefully you don't hear them.
Good morning, everybody.
I hope this is way early for me, usually.
Oh, the music stopped.
Today is Konami Press Start, which is all about Metal Gear and Silent Hill.
Which, I'm very excited for both of those.
So I was like, well, I'll do a watch along of this because I'll be up anyway to watch it.
But also, I'm so annoyed that tomorrow they have a Metal Gear Hotline coming out.
So, why?
I will not be doing a watch along of the Metal Gear Hotline.
Watching from work.
Oh, thank you, guys.
If you're at work.
Or if you woke up early for this.
To watch with me.
Thank you.
What the heck is a hotline?
They've been doing them.
I actually...
I was actually complaining about it the other day.
I was just like, why'd they stop doing the hotlines?
They were just kind of like little updates and like addressing people's concerns.
Because a lot of people were like, Oh, I don't like that they're making Metal Gear without Kojima.
And I don't trust Konami.
And such and such and such.
They heard you complaining.
Yeah, and so they decided to...
You streamed one of them before, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have.
So, then I was like, I'll...
I'll...
I will...
What was I saying?
Oh.
No, I don't know what I was saying.
I wish I could say I stayed up all night to watch with you.
But it was just a happy coincidence.
All night?
Oh my gosh.
Go to bed, please.
Watching Outwork, gang.
Thank you for EU Burnley's dream.
You can thank Konami.
It's not me.
More things into existence.
I guess so.
Hoping for any specific announcements.
I want to see if they talk about MGO and how it will work, mostly.
If there's any special things with that.
Oh my gosh.
In physical moods, thank you so much for the Tony Captain.
Thank you.
Brandon.
Thank you for 14 months.
Hope you are well.
I hope you are well.
You've been going through it, buddy.
Hopefully in the time that I was gone.
Things are better.
14 months.
Thank you.
We know what she's hoping to see.
You guys might be like, oh, we're going to get the crazy reactions from Mito.
No, but I'm so tired.
The one day that the sleepy gummies worked.
I didn't wake up even a little bit.
Usually my cats wake me up also at like 6 to feed them.
And I didn't wake up.
I...
What's a sleepy gummy?
It's just a...
Melatonin...
Gummy.
That's all.
But uh...
Crazy reaction falls asleep.
Maybe if they don't stop...
Wait, what time does it start at?
Oh.
57.
We still have quite a bit of time.
MGS4 gets freed from PS3 soon.
I...
I feel like they'll talk about that tomorrow.
Which makes me a little more upset that I'm doing the watch alone.
But this is also Silent Hill.
But I'm just like...
I want to do both, but...
Like tomorrow, there's a...
There's a Metal Gear Hotline.
Which...
Do they have a waiting room up yet for that?
Let me see.
Metal Gear Hotline.
Like why couldn't it be right after this?
Yeah, they started doing them...
Last year.
We'll be seeing you at this time.
Good morning.
Muhammad, welcome to Bubble Shop.
Thank you.
Been holding on to gifts since last year.
How does one drop them off to you at AX?
Matt...
I don't know how to tell you this, but...
I'm not gonna be at AX.
Like in...
I won't be there.
I'm sorry.
There will be a concert.
But I don't know if they're accepting gifts at it.
Especially because there's so many...
Other...
Talent as well.
So...
Kind of hard.
I've been waiting for that forever.
Gotta wait another year now.
No, no, no.
Shiro, welcome to membership.
Notorious B.S.J., welcome back.
Thank you so much for the five minutes.
Thank you.
Hold on.
I missed some super chats earlier.
Happy 14 months.
Thank you, Taki.
So...
What?
Oh.
Oh, I'm scrolling.
I'm scrolling.
Wait.
Night of Cups.
Silksong.
Yeah.
Silksong will get announced today.
Got called into work overtime this morning.
Oh, did you have...
Good luck with work!
Good.
Good luck!
I would say that off-kai is the best time to give me anything, but...
Unfortunately, I can't accept gifts that off-kai either.
I don't have, like, a...
P.O.
box or anything for people to send to.
I don't have a chance to...
Uhhh...
So...
Right now, it's kind of...
Difficult.
Uh... I'm sorry... Ayami did offer to take my stuff, but I told her that, um... I don't really have time to, like, check everything before... Because she said that they could take it and ship it for me, but I really... I don't really have time... Also,
it's gonna begin in, like, a minute, so... I don't really have time to, uh...
Like, kind of check in, make sure everything's good... Um... And also... Um...
Cash is the best gift now!
Uh...
Yeah, so it's kind of... It's kind of tricky...
Rumble Roses?
I haven't heard that in a long time, that game...
But yeah... So... I'm so sorry...
Let me turn off my music...
We have another countdown...
A countdown to countdown...
You ever feel disappointed...
Discovering Gray Fox's red glow-y thing...
Isn't his eye...
And his helmet's actual eyes are next to it...
No, I've never...
I've never been disappointed in Gray Fox ever...
Good morning, Gameboy!
Sucky, thank you so much for the 5GP...
I love it!
Oh, let me get smaller, too...
Before I forget...
I'll hang out...
With you guys over here...
Hang out with you guys over here...
Boy, boy, Mothman!
Where did you become extra boy?
Thank you so much for the 10-10!
Thank you!
Oh, okay...
I love...
Countdown...
I'm ending the stream...
I can't...
I'm gonna cut that out...
I'm gonna eat my own meal...
And pretend that...
I never...
I've never...
I was trying to say...
I love...
Countdowns!
But I'm tired...
I never say that word, ever...
No!
The Morning Bean Doge is so real!
Okay, it's starting!
It's starting!
It's the trailer...
Can I just show the trailer again?
A quiet wish...
To bring joy to someone...
Somewhere...
Wait, let me turn off the subtitle...
From that flame of passion...
Konami games are born...
Wait, is there an English subtitle?
There we go!
Oh, wow!
Oh, Konami Code!
My name is Noriyaki Okamura...
And I am the producer of the Metal Gear series...
That's...
The subtitle was wrong!
Today, we've prepared an extended version of our recent trailer...
With a few more new details...
Please take a look!
Okay!
I have that shirt!
It's in English!
Ocelot!
Where's Ocelot?
We're under fire!
We've seen all this, luckily...
Alright, Commander!
That's me!
That's me in the trees!
What's the matter?
I'm over here!
Come back to your own room!
Robin!
Yeah!
It was the Robin!
I'm over here!
I've seen some people...
Kind of complaining that these...
Trailers...
Are a little bit spoilery...
But at the same time...
I feel like if they didn't show anything...
People would be...
So upset...
I feel like they would be like...
Why aren't you showing...
Look at this big old grid!
I feel like if they...
Oh!
We actually get to see...
Snake vs.
Bomberman!
I'll be honest...
I forgot...
No shot!
We're there bringing back...
Secret Theater for real?!
Yeah!
Them too!
But um...
Yeah, I feel like people will be like...
Oh!
You're not showing us anything of the game!
Any of the cutscenes!
It probably...
Sucks!
It's ugly!
And more...
I like the extended trailer was just...
Adding...
The...
The bomber...
Re-balance some things?
What does that mean?
Wait a second...
Of the ape escape crossover mode...
Snake vs.
People monkey!
For the Xbox version...
We collaborated with another...
Konami series...
Bomberman...
To create...
Snake vs.
Bomberman...
Where you'll enter the jungle...
To chase down and blast away...
Bomberman...
Alongside...
Snake vs.
Monkey...
The much requested...
Secret Theater...
Also makes a return...
Oh my god...
Yes!
Secret Theater videos...
Will now be found as...
Collectors in games...
In addition...
There are also...
All new...
Secret Theater videos...
Metal Gear Solid...
Delta...
Snake Eater...
They'll be secretly...
Carried by enemy soldiers...
So try to track...
Shut up...
The sneaking DLC pack...
Contains unique...
That's so fun...
Special appearances and effects...
In game...
The player can also...
Find and enjoy...
Secret and specialized...
Items...
Weapons...
And uniforms...
To use and enjoy...
Infiltration situations...
And of course...
One more thing...
I can't wait for the new secret...
Fox Hunt...
I'm Yu Sahara...
The director for Fox Hunt Mode...
And Metal Gear Solid Delta...
Snake Eater...
Fox Hunt is a completely original...
Online multiplayer mode...
Though it shares the same world...
With Metal Gear Solid Delta...
Snake Eater...
The gameplay is completely different...
When we say Metal Gear Multiplayer...
Many fans will probably think of...
Metal Gear Online...
But Fox Hunt...
Will be its own...
New type of mode...
Oh...
Praise for MGO...
We very much appreciate...
All the longtime fans of MGO...
Who have always wanted to see it...
Make a comeback...
I never got to play it...
But the landscape of multiplayer games...
Has changed a lot...
Since MGO...
It took a lot of...
Careful consideration...
To think about...
What a new online mode...
Should look like...
Based on the iconic...
Stealth and survival elements...
In the Metal Gear series...
We are taking...
Camouflage and hide-and-go-seek...
To the next level...
Oh no...
It's...
It's Prop Hut...
To make something unique...
That is more than...
Just a shootout...
We've used that...
Back and forth tension...
Of staying hidden...
Or searching out the enemy...
To create an online experience...
Unique to Metal Gear...
But I want to play as Ocelot...
In a new form...
Please?
Those are all the details...
We can share with you...
For now...
But we're working hard...
On getting Fox Hunt...
To you all...
What?
We plan to have more news...
On Fox Hunt...
In the future...
So please...
Stay tuned...
About the game...
As it develops...
The game...
Should be developed...
It comes out...
In like...
Two months...
Oh...
And the Moa...
So look forward to hearing...
Even more about...
What's coming...
In Metal Gear Solid Delta...
Snake Eater...
Thank you...
Oh...
I'm glad it's not another...
Battle Royale...
Hm...
No way...
Hi, it's Ramold Carpon.
I'm executive... These guys are infiltrating the stream.
I'm Mika Tanguy, art director.
And I'm Gilles Jha, creative director.
Hey!
This wasn't part of the plan.
This wasn't on the schedule.
This is the game that looks like Metal Gear, though.
What?
They didn't even say, like, oh, excuse us for, uh...
For, uh, you know, interrupting your scheduling program.
Is that all that they're gonna say about Metal Gear?
He's been bamboozled!
To use all of these abilities to progress through the adventure and return to the ocean.
Are they gonna show the MGS2 room?
We'd like to thank everyone who gave us such a warm welcome when we announced the game a few months ago.
Ooh.
So thank you all.
We can't wait for you to try out the game.
See you soon.
No, they didn't even show it.
I thought they were gonna be like, look at this room.
Doesn't it remind you of Metal Gear or something?
What's happening?
Oh my god!
We got bamboozled for real!
Can you play a snake in this game?
Come on.
Or something.
Who are these people?
I don't know Miles Edgeworth.
I don't know.
Apparently one of them is a Messi.
That guy is famous.
This is not a snake.
I don't even know how to react right now.
I woke up for this for 10...
Not even 10 minutes of Metal Gear.
They showed the same trailer.
How much can you show of soccer?
The game has been the same for like 100 years.
I don't know.
I'm eating my oatmeal.
Is that Messi on the right?
Me on the right?
Not the fiddle.
Yeah, we did get...
They played us like a damn fiddle.
Football.
It's literally called Football TM.
Oh, it's free to play.
MLB Pro Spirit.
I'm going to curl myself right now.
Pro Spirit is a mobile baseball game where you can play with all 30 MLB teams and their real-life lineups.
I don't care about sports.
Make it easy to feel like you're on the field anytime, anywhere.
Wait a second, though.
Everybody in the comments was crying about...
...was crying about Castlevania.
Like in the pre-chat.
If they're not only just...
And I was like, they're only going to talk about Metal Gear and Silent Hill.
Sillies.
Why would they talk about Castlevania?
Wait, so wait.
What if they actually do?
Rising 2.
That'd be crazy.
Mother Baseball.
That would be...
Such a good...
Game.
In...
Like...
For 5.
Oh my gosh.
I would learn the rules of baseball.
At least show Power Pro.
I'm sick of these 3D people.
On my tiny phone.
Enjoy real MLB action with real quality and real detail.
You could just watch it.
On TV.
For fans of gaming.
People would...
For fans of MLB.
People will go crazy for Otani, though.
For fans of Shohei Otani.
MLB Pro Speaks.
Download now.
Do you like baseball?
Do you like...
Shohei Otani?
Hello, Yu-Gi-Oh fans.
My name is Grant Williams.
Professional basketball player for the Charlotte...
Basketball?
No, this is Yu-Gi-Oh.
I'm a huge Yu-Gi-Oh fan.
Not only just Yu-Gi-Oh Master Duel, but the anime I watched continuously growing up.
As a Yu-Gi-Oh Master Duel player, I've experienced a lot of challenges.
Whether it's trying to find a new Twix called a new Exodia deck...
Exodia...
Trying to take down this Trap Tricks deck.
I know that it takes a lot of skill and a lot of courage.
Not only to build the right deck, but also to be the most skillless Duelist.
I can't remember what deck I used to build.
The Road to Worlds as well as the World Championships.
I want to wish you all luck.
And I want you guys to continue to believe in the hard of the cards.
Because you never know who your next opponent might be.
Who's pitcher and who's catcher?
The biggest stage of Yu-Gi-Oh TCG.
The WCS 2025 qualifiers.
The World Championship qualifiers will be held on the following schedule.
South America WCQ June 6-8.
That...
Central America WCQ July 4-6.
Oceana WCQ July 5-6.
North America WCQ July 11-13.
Europe WCQ July 25-27.
Aim for the World Champion.
What if someone was...
What was it?
South America?
What if they were like...
I'm so ready for the championships.
Announce it.
I've been...
I've been practicing my whole life.
Party?
I never thought...
It was such a sportsman.
Anime.
Sports.
Wee-hee.
Crane-y.
Crane-crane-deck-yea.
Okay, I'm gonna turn off the subtitles since...
Yuki-oh card game, The Chronicles?
Anime?
Promotional short anime series.
The stories that lie within the cards come to life.
Oh.
Kaiba.
Suikoden.
I feel so bamboozled right now.
Am I an idiot for assuming they were only going to talk about Metal Gear and Silent Hill?
Because those are the only things on the...
Duna and Unification Wars.
And I am Tetsuya Agushi, the director for this title.
I really thought.
They said and more?
Oh, did they?
I only saw that they were going to talk about those two in the picture.
And I said, okay, I'll be there.
I got baited by the thumbnail.
I was like, what are they going to talk about here and not in the hotline tomorrow?
God damn it.
I put too much honey and it all went into the bottom of my oatmeal.
So it's like super sweet.
They are like, Suikoden.
Suikoden.
Starly.
I am Shinya Fujimatsu, producer of Suikoden Starly.
Okay, now I'll turn those subtitles back on.
Mucho Texto.
Did you just say it's a mobile game?
I actually don't mind if things are mobile games as long as they're not like so...
Pay to...
You know...
Unlock stuff.
I actually don't mind.
Because it's just like...
So many people are used to...
Portable gaming anyway.
If it's gotcha, then it's kind of like...
You know...
But if it's just like...
Oh, you just buy the game and it's on your phone.
It's amazing.
Wow, that was so nice.
Oh, there they go.
Very slowly.
It looks really nice.
I don't know anything about it.
I don't know anything about Suiko.
Hoping that more people around the world can enjoy the world of Suikoden, we've decided to launch the game globally on Steam so that it can be played on PCs in addition to mobile devices.
Oh!
There you go!
We have also opened our Steam store today.
So it's on Steam, too!
I love this trend of bringing mobile games to Steam.
I actually am such a fan.
They're bringing Blue Archive to Steam.
I was like, woohoo!
I'm such a fan.
Free-to-play includes in-game purchases.
There it is.
It seems almost like an ad for the game coming out, Sam's.
Gradius.
In-game purchases.
You pay $4.99 to get rid of ads.
I remember playing this at my dentist's office.
I would play Gradius at the dentist.
And only there.
Why dentists have console?
I don't know.
They were like, the children are bored.
Salamander 3!
I guess it's just a collection.
We thank you from the bottom of our hearts.
Awww.
Series stuff and fans.
Why does it seem so final?
Winston, sir.
Winston Green.
Wait.
This seems like my kind of game.
I've seen them posting about this before, but...
We deliver anything.
Wait.
I didn't realize this game was so awesome.
Are you blind?
Wait.
I saw them advertising this, but I was like, oh, it's just, you know, car game.
I didn't...
Wait.
I didn't realize it was so awesome.
We're driving ourselves on completing every delivery.
We're reshaping the very essence of delivery services.
Efficiency.
There he goes.
Hey, that delivery is mine to make.
Oh, you just stole it.
There he goes.
The beginning.
This is a GTA 6, everybody?
I don't know off about you, kid.
I just...
know it.
I've never encountered a case as unprecedented as this one.
You think you can push me around?
Well, I have news for you.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa!
Courier boy.
Wait, there's mystery?
What is this game?
What?
Wait.
This game seems like a hundred percent... There's aliens?!
Deliver All Costs is a narratively driven action game where everything is destructible, where you follow a character...
That's all you needed to say!
Time for a spiral towards insanity!
Deliver All Costs is a game that puts you in the shoes of this very unlikely everyday man who is put upon and frustrated with all the troubles that every one of us has experienced in their everyday life.
But you have this perfect opportunity to let loose and explore this world and destroy it.
If you should want to.
And you will be constantly challenged and...
I will be challenged.
And hopefully you will also constantly be given reasons to laugh.
Wait, this game seems awesome.
Very subtle.
Just in time.
Uh oh.
I think I hear the leaf blower again.
Oh, I was about to say, isn't this fairy tale?
Same artist.
Oh!
Well...
If you like the game, I guess.
Oh!
You wanted Metal Gear?
Here's...
E-T-E-R-U-G-E-R!
I'm gonna...
Oh wait!
It was an anime and now it's a game.
Oh gosh.
I can't keep up.
I can't keep up!
Oh!
Oh, not too great Shiki and happy happy.
And Lucy Rebecca.
That really does look like happy.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Who is Shiki?
That's literally just happy, no?
The little cat!
Save data can be carried over.
Nice.
We've made it.
Tough decisions.
To make Metal Gear Delta an epic game store...
What is this?
I...
What?
What is this?
This is Metal Gear Survive.
All these games are Metal Gear, guys.
You just don't realize it.
Finders keepers.
I stole a turtle.
No inventory management.
Wait, you don't have inventory?
Or...
You have to carry everything?
Simple crafting.
Sorry if you can hear the leaf blower.
Wait, what?
Cook food to get stronger.
Short, fast-paced play sessions.
So you just...
Be a smarty pants.
Wait, where's the...
The danger?
Solve puzzles.
Wait, where's the danger?
Kids game.
Yeah, it seems really chill.
It kind of seems fun.
I'm a survival kid.
So a snake.
He puts on the camo and he goes...
Survival.
Up to four kids.
The cat is named Happy in both Fairy Tail and Eden Zero, but he's a robot.
Oh, interesting.
There's no failure to the game either.
You can complete the puzzle.
Killed the interview yesterday.
Thanks for the luck.
That's cool!
Exploring it, completing the puzzle, and then building a raft, and then escaping.
You can come back...
Bandai.
There's hidden objects in the world.
There's fish to fire.
Wrong...
There's...
...company.
He's combo.
I like the little laser.
Oh, I thought he was your pet.
Oh my.
Finders keepers.
Oh!
Wait, this is a sequel?
To an anime game?
Wait!
What?
We had a tremendous amount of fun making the game.
We should have made it more anime.
The players enjoy playing it as much as we enjoyed making it.
It was on Game Boy.
How do you...
How do you multiplayer that?
Oh!
It's time!
For the other thing I woke up for.
Here, I'll turn off the subtitles.
Did you guys see the article about...
The main actress being like when I was filming this game.
I think I was going insane.
Oh, yes please.
Silent Hill was a series that fused the essence of Western horror and Japanese horror.
But as the series progressed...
Then it's good.
Mmhmm.
Exactly.
I began to feel a desire to create a Silent Hill with 100% essence of Japanese style horror.
Wow.
If I were to create a Silent Hill with a Japanese aesthetic, I believed that a production team from Japan or Asia would be ideal.
At that time, I came across Neobards.
I felt they were a great team...
Neobards...
...as they had worked with several major Japanese publishers and were able to communicate smoothly.
We're going to just dox their building.
Our team, Neobards, has been working together for almost 20 years.
We're thrilled that our past work caught the attention of producer, Okamoto, leading to this collaboration.
He's the origami killer.
Many members of our team are long time fans of Silent Hill and Ryokishio 7.
We also began having in-depth discussions...
...and I'm going to try to develop a game experience...
He's got so many origami's!
...within a Japanese atmosphere.
With the major thematic shift, it was absolutely critical for us to not merely copy, but really understand what the key atmospheric elements that defined the classic Silent Hill titles were.
Yes.
In order to involve them...
That is so terrifying.
So we spent a lot of time iterating and discussing between...
That was so scary!
...and how to bring that uneasy charm and loneliness of Ebisugoka to life.
Keeping in tradition with the Silent Hill series, our protagonist Tinako is also designed to be an ordinary person.
However, it was crucial to us to have fun and interesting gameplay.
For Silent Hill F, the team spent a lot of time focusing on creating a combat system that would feel both fresh but familiar.
I was literally telling... I went to Daiso.
I was telling my friend they have the foam swords there.
And I was like, oh my gosh, those are always the foam swords you see used at mocap studios.
The setting of Silent Hill F are shifting from the town of Silent Hill to Japan.
She was using it!
But it remains a psychological horror experience where one confronts themselves within a mental world.
Taking into account that it's a psychological horror horror...
We sought to enhance the essence of Japanese-style horror.
The hallmark of Japanese horror is not simply grotesqueness, but the coexistence of beauty and the disturbing.
We are creating this title with a concept, Find the Beauty in Terror.
As a key concept in Silent Hill F is the idea of beauty and terror.
Sorry.
We created our visual designs to have a distinct uneasiness to them.
Oh, it looks so good.
But also have a worth of charm that would make it so you just couldn't stop staring.
In this matter, we were extremely fortunate to be able to work with Kerasan to design our key character art as their designs perfectly suited the ideal of beauty and terror.
Gorgeous.
Oh my god.
Regarding the setting, we carefully considered which era would provide stage and environment that could depict the theme of the story with a higher contrast.
And I chose it accordingly.
I need the art book for this, like, so bad.
I need it right now.
Oh my god.
The show era, though just half a century ago, feels like a different world.
One that remains connected to our present, yet preserves customs and superstitions long forgotten in modern life.
I hope you'll enjoy that contrast as well.
Another key reason we chose this time frame and location was that there were many, many elements we could draw from that would both feel familiar, yet alien to many players, supporting that sense of uneasiness.
When designing the levels, we began by using the Kinkatsu area of Kinsan Town as a foundation, then selected several representative Japanese locations, such as Dagashiya, schools, shrines, and more.
These locations, with their strong Showa era atmosphere, help immerse the levels in a distinctly Japanese setting.
Of course, we haven't forgotten the other world of Silent Hill, which is a core element of the franchise.
After extensive discussions and iterations, and collaboration with Ryukishi Osu's storyline, we crafted a level experience unique to Silent Hill F.
We believe that for Asian players, these Japanese-style environments will feel familiar.
While for Western players, they will be striking and intriguing.
Through this game, we hope more players can experience a unique aesthetics and design sensibilities of Japanese culture.
We're tackling a type of theme that has never been explored in the Silent Hill series before.
Personally, I believe it's a theme well-suited to the world of Silent Hill.
But I'll leave it to all of you to decide whether it truly fits.
We had countless discussions with Neobards about direction and expression throughout development.
Ryukishi, you madman.
I truly feel that everything we hoped to convey through the scenario was fully understood and embraced by the team.
Ryukishi 7 is scriptwriter?
Oh yeah, that's why people are so excited for this game.
One of our core development goals was to make sure Ryukishi...
It's actually peak.
Like, this game is gonna be insane.
I can't wait.
Oh my god.
...is very, very different than that of a playable game.
There was a lot of discussion and iteration between our teams on what things would need to be adjusted, why they would need to be adjusted, and how to best go about it.
Why?
For instance, something we had to consider was the flow of the levels in relation to the story.
Such as when to push players along.
They're a little...
They're so bad.
In order to present Ryukishi sounds lower in the most suitable way, we'd organize what information would fit best where.
Such as through environmental storytelling, Fog town.
Secondary information such as a note you'd pick up during gameplay, characterization through animations, VO, etc, etc.
And of course, what parts would be most suitable as a cutscene?
Mm-hmm.
I believe the narrative design of this title is built on one original core element and two fresh new aspects.
The core lies in how we carry forward the unique sense of dread and horror that defines Silent Hill.
The new aspects come from the story crafted by Ryukishi 07, and the gameplay design that complements it.
We carefully considered which moments should create direct stress through gameplay, and which should evoke fear through camera work and composition.
With this title shifting from a Western setting to Japan, we aim not only to reflect that change in the environment, but also to ensure that the performance and presentation evoke a cultural atmosphere that resonates with players.
I'm obsessed.
Oh!
Ew!
Oh my god.
That's nasty.
Beautiful.
God, this game is so beautiful.
Oh!
It's so...
Oh, it's so pretty.
My god.
Oh my gosh.
I can't stop gushing about it.
It's so pretty.
Oh!
I'm so excited.
What?
Oh!
Silent Hill Rubik!
They're working with Bloober again.
But people...
People really liked...
People really liked Silent Hill 2, so...
I will give them a second chance.
Was that it?
Yeah, they said I was gonna be pretty short.
They said it was gonna be about this long, so...
Um...
Oh!
You can't...
40% off?
Okay, wait.
I can grab it.
Cool.
Was that everything?
That was everything, right?
Wait, how much is it?
Hold on.
I'm gonna go check.
Silent Hill 2.
My birthday.
Oh yeah, it really is 40% off.
Nice!
I think it's Bloober remaking Silent Hill 1.
Yeah!
It said it.
On the screen.
Um...
Should we watch, uh...
We could watch, um...
The...
We could watch...
The Metal Gear part again.
We could, um...
Rewatch the Metal Gear part to feel like there's...
Um...
A quiet wish.
To bring joy to someone, somewhere.
From that flame of passion, Konami games are born.
Silent Hill remake, though.
That's exciting.
Are the dogs gonna... I always think of that one screenshot of, um...
Of, what's his name, being in front of the dog house, and then there's the dog coming at him.
And he's like, I think there's a dog here.
Give us frame by frame description.
Wait.
Sorry, I want to look at everything now.
I do want to take a look.
Nah.
Oh no, this is the area with the dogs.
They haven't shown us the dogs yet.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Hold on.
Sorry.
I'll turn it down a little since I'll be starting and stopping it.
Look at that bird.
I'm gonna eat that bird.
No dogs yet.
Oh.
The fire.
This is when you climb up the hill, and you have to crawl into the little hidey-hows.
That guy?
You know he's close.
I love the way the Crockat kind of goes like...
And the traps.
Look how nasty he is.
Enemy position unknown.
Oh.
Golly.
They just made the secret Rykov behind.
It's so funny.
Cute.
I know we've already seen this before.
Alright, Commander.
Floating like this.
It's a revolution.
Alright, Commander.
Ender.
Wow, they did a really good job.
There's nobody in there.
There's nobody in there, River.
There's nobody there.
Oh, wait.
Unless he's already reached the end of it.
He's pretty close.
I love the effect there.
When he...
This...
That...
It looks so awesome.
Whoa.
The lighting in here is actually kind of insane.
That was like the first thing I noticed.
It's so dark.
Like, what happened to the lights?
In the original, like, you're in a warehouse.
Everybody is...
It's work hours.
Pacifist run.
Yeah, exactly.
Looks like he's in a fighting game.
It looks awesome.
Vulcan looks so good in this game.
I mean, everybody looks so good.
I was really worried how they'd do Eva.
Because I did not like how she looked in a...
In...
In the patchy slot.
But Eva in this game...
She looks hot.
She looks so good.
Hold on.
I want to see Snake's stupid little grin.
That's so cute.
Gotcha.
My boy's cheesing.
He's so excited.
He's so excited to hold the monkey.
Dad and son.
Gotcha.
Missile gear.
I love...
Oh my gosh.
The cut scenes in Japanese from that game were so funny.
Because Snake would be like...
What are you gonna do now?
And also...
Wait.
Now that I think about it...
That was David Hayter, no?
Well...
So we'll actually have David Hayter's voice...
For...
For Snake vs.
Monkey.
Because...
Original Snake vs.
Monkey...
In English is not David Hayter.
That's huge!
Wait.
That's actually...
I just thought about that.
That's actually so big.
Young Eva or Old Eva?
Both.
I didn't even think about that.
Who was Snake in the original?
I don't know, but...
The guy does not sound like Snake at all.
It's actually so funny.
I mean...
But...
But in the cutscene, Snake will be like...
What are you gonna do?
And then you just hear the monkey go...
K, k, k, k, k, k...
K, k, k, k, k...
K, k, k, k...
Hold on, let me see.
Maybe I can find like a video.
Hold on.
So you guys can hear it.
If you haven't heard it before.
Snake versus monkey.
Oh wait, I'm getting like actual snakes.
Monkey versus snake battle.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Wait, this one maybe.
This is like the ending cutscene, but...
Hold on.
Hold on, let me go to the cutscene.
Okay, here.
That's snake!
That's supposed to be snake!
Hold on, let me...
Let me, here, I'll get it up.
No, that is not solid snake.
Oh wait, how does the capture look?
I might have to readjust it.
There we go.
Oh, whoops.
So you're an... agent, huh?
Sure are one brave little monkey.
It doesn't sound like it.
Sure are by as you've got there.
Anyway, I guess we brought the world back from the brink of catastrophe.
It was all due to you.
Woo...
Hee-hee!
By the way, you haven't been properly introduced yet.
I'm Snake.
You can call me that from now on.
And you...
Hee-hee-hee-hee-hee-hee?
Kiki... Kiki... Interesting.
A pair of snakes.
Nice to meet you, Snake.
I think we are going to get along just fine.
Kiki... Kiki... Kiki... Kiki... Kiki... Kiki... Kiki... Sometimes I just quote that.
Sometimes I'll just be like...
Kiki... Kiki... Kiki... Kiki... But yeah, anyway.
Maman... Do you think Grimalo will be in the game?
This though?
Secret theater?
I'm so excited!
God, I wish.
What was this called?
Fox Hunt?
I think.
Not M.G.O.
Little different from M.G.O.
Hmm...
I'm Yuji Korakaru, the creative producer.
For this trailer, we wanted to focus on the gameplay.
Peter Luriet, the voice of Snake.
Oh...
Kiki has come too.
I feel... I saw some people being like...
Oh, why are they exclusive...
To...
I think because...
Licensing.
You guys.
I feel like...
That's why.
Licensing is always such an issue.
So...
Uh...
Yeah.
In the Xbox version, we collaborated with another Konami series, Bomberman, to create Snake vs Bomberman.
Where you'll enter the jungle to chase down and blast away Bomberman.
To be fair...
Well...
I personally...
I...
I want the...
I want Monkey more than Bomberman, so...
Uh...
It's no issue for me, but...
I get it.
The much requested secret theater also makes a return.
In the remake, the original secret theater videos will now be found as collectibles in-game.
So I have to shake them down?
In addition...
This though.
Hello?
All new secret theater videos made from...
Wait, is this our first time seeing Sokolov?
This is so...
What is this face?
This is horrifying.
Metal Gear Solid Delta Snake Eater.
They'll be secretly carried by enemy soldiers.
So try to track them down.
Oh, how many will there be?
We saw them before.
Oh, I just forgot then.
How many will there be?
I guess the original ones and then...
At least two.
Gotta shake them down.
Look at this.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
I also wanted to stop it earlier.
It was going so fast.
Oh, my gosh.
It looks so good.
It looks like...
Like a...
Like a Japanese armor, you know?
Sneaking...
The Sneaking...
The Sneaking DLC pack contains...
Oh...
Neat uniforms with special appearances and effects.
In-game, the player can also find and enjoy secret and specialized items, weapons, and uniforms to use and enjoy...
I can't...
He's just wagging it in front of his face.
...
Good snake.
This was just images you can hear.
You can just hear the way that he does.
And of course, one more thing.
Fox Hunt.
Oh, they have the tubs.
They have the... I only have one of them actually.
Oh, I have these also.
I got them from TGS.
The calorie mate.
I have them.
I have them frame.
Original online multiplayer mode.
Though it shares the same world with Metal Gear Solid Delta Snake Eater, the gameplay is complete.
Wait, what was that?
Though it shares the same world with Metal Gear Solid Delta Snake Eater.
Oh, he's like putting on the... Whoa.
Whoa.
He's just like, deploy camo.
Octo camo.
The handkerchief is equally distant between Snake and the guard.
The guard passes.
Snake is built differently.
We very much appreciate all the long-time fans of M.G.O.
who have always wanted to see it make a comeback.
But the landscape of multiplayer games has changed a lot since M.G.O.
That's crazy.
It took a lot of careful consideration to think about what a new online mode.
Please let us play as like other characters though.
Based on the iconic stealth and survival elements in the Metal Gear series, We are taking camouflage and hide-and-go-seek to the next level.
I don't want to just play as the soldiers.
I like to see what's going on in here.
What's going on in here?
What you got going on?
Hmm.
I'm happy that you're going to off-glide.
Yeah, even though I wasn't as a guest, I kind of found some ways to sneak in a little bit.
So...
We've used that back-and-forth tension of staying hidden or searching out the enemy to create an online experience unique to Metal Gear.
Oh...
Those are all the details we can share with...
What's going on in there?
Also, this like...
Radar is kind of crazy.
PS5.
Yeah, he's playing on the PS5.
Maybe.
For now, but we're working hard on getting Fox Hunt.
To you all.
I can't see anything.
It's too blurry.
We plan to have more news on Fox Hunt in the future.
So please, stay tuned.
Hmm...
Wait.
Oh no, that might just be...
The Ocelot Team...
Uniform.
I dissect.
Snack!
Hehehehe.
Ah!
Woo!
I can't wait to get mine.
I pre-ordered the version with this statue.
It looks so good!
Oh my god!
I didn't even notice it the first time.
It looks so good!
Look at that!
I'm doing the foley!
Hehehehehehe.
Hehehehe.
Oh yeah.
My boy's gonna sound like a trash bag.
Hehehehe.
Wait, since we have the hotline tomorrow...
Snake is shirtless.
Yeah, take a damn.
The game comes out in like a month and a half.
It comes out in like a month and a half.
What is the hotline?
So the hotline is something that they were doing...
They started last year, kind of just like updates about...
Metal Gear Delta and like the Metal Gear releases and stuff.
And...
Just like its own focus on Metal Gear.
Yeah, new stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
So they have one tomorrow.
Which they only just announced like...
The day before.
So I would have probably put that on my schedule instead of this.
But this was still fun because I obviously...
I put this because I was very excited about...
Silent Hill.
Oh gosh, hold on.
I also wanna go look at these again.
Show me the art, baby.
Show me the art.
This game is so pretty.
Hold on.
There was like some things I was like...
Dang.
Ugh!
She's so cute!
I wanna see more of the monsters.
I don't remember where they were at though.
But this one...
They talked a lot about Silent Hill.
Which makes sense because they've...
Talked at many lengths about Metal Gear already.
Do you think they'll talk about Master Collection Volume 2 tomorrow?
Or closer to TGS?
I...
I wouldn't...
Put it out of...
The...
You know...
For them to talk about it.
Maybe even announce it.
If they don't say so much about it.
Hmm.
God!
Look at that thing!
It's like hopping!
It's so cute!
Where are the...
Scarecrow ladies?
I can't...
I can't see!
Everything was so fast!
Oh, I see it like this.
Ugh!
It's perfect!
It's so good!
I can't wait!
Ugh!
Look, they're like holding the...
The...
The blade...
It's so good!
Gosh, it's such a good design!
I wonder if it's based off of them because...
Wait a second...
This looks like the boy!
Huh...
Like it's the same haircut, you know?
Hmm...
I wonder...
I wonder, I wonder...
Same uniform...
Yeah, I wonder if it's like kind of...
Storyline...
We crafted a level...
People experience unique to Silent Hill F.
We believe that for Asian players...
These Japanese style...
It's so pretty!
Oh gosh, it's so pretty!
Let's see...
I wanna like...
There was other...
There was another like...
Or maybe here...
Sorry...
I'm skipping through...
He-he!
I can't get over...
Wait, they even have the uniforms in the office!
This...
That's awesome!
I guess to see like...
How it would move in certain situations...
The team spent a lot of time...
Focusing on creating a combat system...
That would feel both fresh...
Oh my gosh!
The way they move!
Woohoo!
Never occurred to me that normal Silent Hill seems normal to us...
And foreign to Japanese players...
Yeah!
Right!
Like...
Yeah!
Hmm...
I never thought about that really either too!
Oh, that's cool!
I'm concerned it won't have anything to do with...
Or it will retcon the entire cult and origin stuff with Silent Hill...
I think...
Hmm...
How to say...
Uh...
I think it will probably be its...
Be its own thing...
But...
I think...
How do I say...
Sorry...
I'm thinking...
I think for the most part...
Silent Hill...
I think it can be its own thing...
Cause like...
2 didn't really talk so much about it...
They brought it back in 3...
But like...
Crazy take, I know...
Hahaha...
I think honestly...
My...
My opinion of...
How...
Silent Hill is...
Is like...
This...
And this is a really Japanese concept...
Which is...
Is that...
Hold on...
Sorry...
How do I explain the...
Without sounding like a...
N...
Nutcase...
If... there are enough strong feelings, a case of Silent Hill can occur.
Does that make sense?
So like, it's like, okay, you know how like with... with... the... you guys get what I was trying to say?
That's super normal?
Okay, you get it?
Okay, cool.
Like, it's almost... it's almost like... like with, you know, the grudge, you know, like with Juon.
Where it's just like... they say... they say if enough... if a powerful of enough... grudge happens upon death, then the curse is born, etc, etc.
Yeah, it's not a set location.
It's kind of like a...
It's... it's the... it's the...
You guys get what I'm trying to say?
I'm just... I'm still waking up.
More of a state of a mind than a place.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Miraculous ladybug!
Exactly!
You get akumatized.
You get akumatized and then you are in Silent Hill.
Trauma manifestations.
That... yes.
That.
So that's why I'm just like, you know, Silent Hill doesn't have to be like, you know, surrounding this certain...
entity, the cult or whatever, whatever.
Because, you know...
That's just one aspect of it.
So...
We'll see.
Akumatized into pyramid heads.
That's horrible.
What if...
What if ladybug is its own form of Silent Hill?
What if in Paris everybody's...
It's so...
It's...
I've always joked because, like, you know, obviously due to, like, animation and...
limited budgets and everything, they could only animate so many people.
But when I was...
I was really into Ladybug for...
for a hot minute.
And, like, me and my friends, we would watch it together.
And we would always joke that there's, like, five people who live in Paris.
And that just...
That's just...
Those are the five people stuck in Paris Hill.
But they're...
And constantly getting akumatized.
I sadly can't vibe with psycho horror games.
Oh!
Yeah, I guess...
Some people...
It's not some people's type...
Cup of tea.
I...
I love...
For the most part, any kind of horror.
I think psychological horror has been...
way overdone...
at this point.
But...
With Silent Hill...
At least with this...
I...
I trust.
Maybe I'm a fool for putting in so much trust, but...
I trust Ryukishi7.
So...
I don't know.
Time for me to wake up and go to work.
Have a good day at work!
I love the vibe.
I...
I keep calling it Fatal Frame Silent Hill.
And if this is the closest I'll get to another Fatal Frame.
Fine.
Fine!
And I'm just gonna talk while it plays so I can see more...
More spooky things.
This...
Hold on.
I noticed this too.
These eyeballs are so creepy.
I was talking about like a...
The...
Uneasiness during this part.
And I was like...
Ew!
Creepy!
This...
Gosh!
It looks so good.
Ugh!
I love horror!
I love horror.
The choppy movement.
I know.
Chef's kiss.
So...
So good.
So, so, so stink.
And then...
The...
I'm obsessed!
I'm so obsessed.
I'm so obsessed!
Oh my god.
I'm so obsessed.
Oh...
Obsessed.
Anyway.
I'm gonna head out now though, guys!
Uh...
I have another stream tonight.
So, if you want more Mito action, I'll see you then.
And if not...
Hi, Dad!
Thanks, Troy, for this!
I'll see you when I see you next.
He-hee-hee!
Okay!
Thanks, guys, for watching this with me.
Waking up early.
If you had to wake up early.
And if you didn't, then...
Thanks for hanging out!
Nyah!
Yeah!
This game isn't called Loud Valley.
Oh, it's not the opposite of Sal- I was like, what's Loud Valley?
Logan!
Thank you so much for the fun.
Good to take you!
Just came home from work.
Might nap.
Good night!
Bye-bye!
Thank you, guys!
See you!
Bye-bye!
I'm gonna go take a nap.